here's a pretty great story not many of
them we search high and low to find them
so last month people driving through
Paterson New Jersey noticed something
weird seven sheep were wandering around
they just escaped a slaughterhouse
police later rounded all the Sheep up
sheep are not allowed to wander on the
highway in Patterson and here's the
happy ending these sheep are not going
back to the slaughterhouse kind of like
when The Hangman's rope breaks
you're free so the Sheep are now at
these Skylands Animal Sanctuary in
Sussex County New Jersey
John decando is an animal control
officer Mike stura is the founder of
skyline Sanctuary animal rescue and they
join us tonight oh thank you thank you
guys so much for coming so officer first
to you if you would what did you see
what were these sheep doing when you
apprehended them
Tucker was around maybe around six
o'clock in the morning uh 9-1-1 calls
were coming in the Paterson Police
Department that were sheeps running
around in town and uh we got there it
was unbelievable we had three sheeps
trapped in one place one sheep was down
by Dunkin Donuts and the other one was
down by Stevie mattress and it wasn't
easy getting them because they weighed
about 200 pounds each but once they
escaped from The Slaughterhouse they're
not ever going back there they're going
to the sanctuary we end up getting two
sheeps we put them back at two police
cars and we escort them to the animal
shelter and a lights and Sirens all the
way up to the shelter we came back and
We rescued the other ones and uh you had
to see it it was something something
unbelievable well if if I could just
really quickly single out the Sheep at
Dunkin Donuts for a second what did he
order
I think it was uh I don't know probably
cream late one sugar and probably a
bagel yeah I'm thinking crawlers but um
I'm not surprised Mike you're a good man
to take these sheep
um they're rescued what's their life
gonna look like now
well Tucker uh they well you're looking
at it they get they uh this is their
this is our cheap barn and they uh they
have a big field up here and uh they
they get to live their life out and
hopefully you know pass away from old
age a long time from now
um yeah they do whatever they want do
they have any sense do you think of how
lucky they are comparing their lives to
their compatriots back at the abattoir I
mean they're they're pretty fortunate
sheep
I'll tell you they're they're um they
pay attention better than we think you
know they've only been here a couple
days and we just got the okay to let
them uh in with some of our other sheep
here and you can see already how much
they've calmed down
um they they know that they're that
they're um safe now or at least they you
know it's the way the others cheap treat
us you know the way they come right up
to us and all that these guys learn that
from you know from them really quick
officer for for others for sheep
watching the show tonight
um any sense of how these guys got out
of the slaughterhouse
well I don't know what happened but uh
they probably opened up a truck and the
guy wasn't watching what he was doing
yeah and the the Sheep said probably now
or never and once I get them they're
going by Mike absolutely
you're you're making me proud to be
American and and it's such an important
point you see an opportunity you take it
um you can wind up with Mike thank you
great to see you both thank you thank
you sir
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight